First and foremost, I'm going to record the video.
Guys real quick, what I want to do this year and especially, well, not especially, but
just in general this year is I want to be, you know, we have our structured Tuesday lives.
I always come prepared.
I usually spend about an hour-ish preparing just for that Tuesday live.
But there's a lot of stuff that I learned, a lot of stuff that comes to my mind, a lot
of stuff that I'm learning as I'm trying to scale to a million dollars a month that I
think you can take and you can bring down and extract the lessons and extract the principles
and learn a lot.
Not to say that I know everything, not to say that I'm the only one that knows how to
do business.
In fact, I probably don't know how to do business that well at all.
I'm humble enough to admit that.
But I do want to start sharing those things with you and sometimes I have this, you know,
I have this big running list of like ideas of lives I want to do.
So I'm going to change that a little bit.
If I have something that I do or that I've learned or that's working for me, I'm just
going to come live and share it and then leave it.
And if you guys see it, great.
If not, no worries.
But I want to start doing more of that.
So happy Monday.
This is completely random this morning as I was, you know, I have my Monday stuff I do
every single Monday that it makes my entire week more productive.
I was doing that and I thought, you know what, this would be super instructive and I think
very important and useful for people to hear.
So Cindy says, can you can hear you?
Happy Monday.
Cindy, thank you.
And my comments are only shown up on my phone, so I'm going to be, you know, going from here
to here.
Adair, what's going on?
Glad to have a couple of people on, but I'm going to leave this live in the group so people
can see this later.
But really quick, what I want to share in the next like literally five, seven minutes
is something that I do every single week, specifically every single Monday that allows
me to get a ton of stuff done.
OK.
It's something that I've perfected over the years and I think it's a very it's a system
that's worked really well for me and I just want to share it with you.
OK, so I'm the type of person that I like to sit with my headphones on, undistracted
phone off like the one of the reasons I like being in Dubai or Africa is because I'm so
far ahead that by the time people can even wake up, I've already got a lot of that like,
you know, that important work, the working on the business, not in the business stuff.
I think it's very valuable where I can sit with my thoughts and solve problems and then
create solutions for my company.
However, sometimes I get a little bit too extreme with that and I end up like not utilizing
what I have, the resources that I have.
OK, so obviously within your business, you have different forms of leverage, right?
Some of like, for example, there's money is a form of leverage.
Media is a form of leverage and humans, human capital is a form of leverage.
So what I want to just share with you really quick is how I how I get a lot of stuff done
throughout the week.
Actually, I get a lot of stuff done Monday through Wednesday.
I get I get 90 percent of what I get done during the week, Monday through Wednesday.
And they're very exhausting, but very busy days, very fulfilling days.
But this is what I do.
So I want to share really quick.
OK, and maybe we may do a longer live that I can actually show you guys my screen.
Nick Cudlick, what's going on, dude?
Hopefully St. George's warming up.
Good to see you guys on.
So, guys, here's what I do.
Every single Sunday.
Now, I haven't been great at this at this this year, but it is something that I am
like, no questions asked.
I'm going to make sure that it is it is a non-negotiable for me
because I'm going back and looking at what were the years I did the best?
What's the years I grew?
I grew the most.
What's the years that I scaled the most?
And what was I doing?
OK, one of the things was I was very, very adamant about month
weekly planning on Sunday and specifically early in the morning
before kids were up, before church, before any of that kind of stuff.
I was very, very disciplined about getting my planning done.
OK. Now, what it does, guys, when you get your plan.
By the way, this isn't a planning topic I'm talking about.
But when you do that weekly planning, first thing in the morning,
you know, when you're thinking, hey, I got to do my planning at 630 a.m.,
it doesn't really encourage you or inspire you to go out on Saturday night.
Right. That's one thing that I've learned.
You get to bed a little bit earlier.
You start thinking, hey, I got to get up.
I got to get that done. OK.
I like to do it in the morning because by the evening, I'm tired.
My creativity is gone.
And on top of that, you know, it's like I, you know, I want to be
I want to give myself a chance to reset.
So first thing that I do, guys, is Sunday morning.
I plan out my entire week.
I have a live that I've done in this group on my weekly planning,
how I do my weekly planning, which you guys can go and you can find.
You can check out. OK. So do that on Monday.
Sorry. On Sunday, Monday, what I do is I set aside an hour.
OK. And sometimes I break it up into 30 minute chunks.
I'll do like 30 minutes. I'll take a five minute break.
I'll do the other 30 minutes.
But what I do, guys, is I have all of the human capital
that I have access to, OK, which is my team. Right.
So just some of the people you guys know, Francesca, Ashley, I've got
Isaac, who is my video guy, I've got Porter.
These are members of my team.
This is my human capital for you guys.
You may have your VA.
You may have your content writer, whatever, whatever, whatever. Right.
And for me, just so you guys know, I also have
my team members that report to me that have their own team members
that report to them, which is another layer of leverage.
So what I do is I have a simple Google document and I title it
2025 weekly priorities and I put the name of the person.
So 2025 weekly priorities, Ashley.
OK. 2025 weekly priorities, Isaac.
And guys, what I do is I go and I look at my weekly plan
and I sit there and I go, what things I look at my top three.
I, you know, my big three that I do, and you guys have to watch my weekly
planning live to understand what I'm talking about.
But I look at my big three things I want to accomplish.
And then I look at all my other tasks and I look and say,
what can I get off of my plate, but still keep moving the needle forward?
And there's things that I personally have to do.
I have to record a podcast.
I can't really outsource that because I'm the one doing it. Right.
But I can outsource the planning.
I can outsource maybe not even the planning, but I can outsource the
the production and the schedule of the post and the commenting
and making sure all of everything's dialed in and editing that I can do.
So I look at my weekly priorities and my weekly planning.
And I'm going to start assigning stuff to different people. Right.
Ashley, this is this falls under her role.
This falls under Francesca's role.
This falls under Porter. This falls under Jason.
This falls under, you know, my guy, Peter here in Africa.
And I start divvying this stuff out and I put it into two categories.
OK. First category I do is stuff that they need to work on.
It's like creative juices.
I need you to put your this is this is the priorities,
the stuff that actually takes, you know, brain power and creativity.
That comes first.
And then underneath that, I call it the managerial stuff.
That's hey, I need you to reschedule a flight for me.
I need you to make sure this is posted stuff that doesn't take a lot of time.
I need you to respond to the Facebook or the YouTube comments,
stuff that doesn't really take a lot of thought, but that needs to be done.
So each one of my team members, I have two different categories.
I have my creative needle moving stuff and then I have my managerial stuff.
And I go and I line them out every single week on Monday.
First thing that I do, exactly the things that are priorities.
And as long as I've communicated the goals of the company,
the way the direction that I want to move as a company and the vision for the company
and then they can see the weekly priorities, I can then go.
And as soon as I've done that, what I'll do, you know, once they wake up
or once I get a chance is I'll hop on with them for, you know, five, 10, 15 minutes.
Like as soon as I get off this, I'm about to hop on with Francesca.
I'm going to hop on with her.
We're going to buzz through it really quick.
And I'm going to clarify anything that she may have a question on
or anything that I want to make sure she really understands.
And then she goes to work.
So for all of Monday, for Monday at 9am for the whole week,
she's completely lined out and she's on her freaking business.
She's doing the task. She knows what's important.
She knows she needs to spend her time.
And then also, guys, there's Francesca calling me right now.
I'm also, well, I then I can go back to work on the stuff
because I have two different categories.
I have the stuff that's needle moving and creative, et cetera.
And then I have the managerial stuff that's like, get the tax paper here.
The only sign this that only I can do.
And then, hey, let's figure out how we can come up with more clients in a one week period.
Let's figure out how we can create better lives.
Let's figure out we can redo this training.
Those are my needle moving activities.
And so, guys, I do this every single week.
I line them out in their Google sheet.
I try to do a quick phone call, a quick Zoom call with them.
Some of the team members that it's really cut and dry do this, this, this and this.
It's a lot of the same stuff every week.
I don't need to do it.
And sometimes and some of the people I have to get on a Zoom like Francesca,
who keeps calling me, by the way.
She's like, where are you at?
And I make sure that we're on the same page.
And guys, by doing this, you're duplicating yourself.
You are then lining your team members out.
It's like you're programming.
I don't want to say a robot, but you're programming human capital
that you're like, hey, do this, this, this and this.
And you also have a very, you know, creative and strong brain.
And these are my team members are really, really smart.
Otherwise, they wouldn't be on my team.
I wouldn't allow them to be on my team.
And then they get to go and work on the stuff
that is going to move the needle in those departments.
And then guess what? On Friday, they send me a quick loom.
If we don't zoom and they say, hey, here was this priority.
Here's what I did. Here was this five minute loom.
Put it on to speed.
Watch it in two minutes. Done.
This right here, guys, is something that I do every single week.
So I've already done my weekly priorities for all my team members,
my human capital.
Now I got to do a couple of zooms and check in with them.
And then I'll be checking in on Slack and stuff midweek.
And then by the end of the week, we either do a quick phone call, zoom,
or they send me a loom via email.
Everyone on my team member sends me a loom on email or Slack.
I then Monday morning or when I'm planning, I watch it quickly.
I'm like, boom, they got everything done.
And on to the next week, guys, this has allowed me to get a lot of stuff done
leveraging human capital, which is something you're already paying for.
If you're not taking the time to line up your VA and tell them
exactly what they should be spending their time doing and the priorities
that they should be, you know, the things they should be prioritizing.
You're leaving a lot of money on the table.
And there's a lot of stuff that could be getting done that's not.
OK, so that said, guys, in lieu or in the same vein of what I'm talking about,
I'm going to hop on with Francesca.
We're going to go over our priorities and I'm going to keep cranking out work, guys.
Happy freaking January.
It's one of the greatest months to do deals.
And I will see you guys tomorrow on the live.
I'm out. See you guys.